وسط جائحة فيروس كورونا ، يشعر الناس بأعراض خفيفة ويمكن أن يواجه الفيروس خيارًا صعبًا إما مغادرة منازلهم لرؤية الطبيب والمخاطرة بتعريض أنفسهم والآخرين أو البقاء في المنزل والتخلي عن المشورة الطبية ، ما يحدث هو أن الناس قلقون من أن الناس لا يخافون. لا أعرف حقًا ما يجب القيام به إلى أين نذهب وما إذا كان ينبغي عليهم إجراء اختبار أم لا ، فنحن نتخلى عن الفيروس ، حيث يأتي التطبيب عن بُعد حيث سيقيم أطباؤنا أنك تعاني من الحمى أو ما هو دبوس درجة الحرارة لديك ، لديك ضيق سعال في نقرات رعاية التنفس شركة طب عن بعد تضم أكثر من 20 مليون مستخدم في جميع أنحاء الولايات المتحدة وتقول إنها شهدت زيادة بنسبة 50 في المائة في المستخدمين في مارس من وجهة نظر المستخدمين أو أن المريض و / أو الطبيب لا يفعلون شيئًا مختلفًا عما سيفعلونه لو حضرت وجهاً لوجه فقط ، فإن الاختلاف الوحيد هو أن لدينا الآن شاشات بيننا بشكل أساسي إلى جانب مزودي الخدمة الآخرين الذين رخصوا نقرات الرعاية التكنولوجية الخاصة بها  تقديم تقييمات covin 19
الخاصة به مجانًا إذا كنت تتناسب مع
المعايير ، فسنحتاج إلى إجراء مكالمة حكم ،
فأنت مريض حقًا ، نعم ، اذهب إلى
المستشفى أو غرفة الطوارئ اطلب
منهم رؤيتك ولكن الأشخاص الذين ليسوا
بهذه الحدة لدرجة أننا  أشعر أننا نجحنا في
الإدارة عن بُعد في
عملية موجهة للتقييم وفقًا
لمركز السيطرة على الأمراض ، فإن
معظم الأشخاص المصابين بـ kovat 19 يعانون من
أعراض خفيفة ويمكنهم التعافي في المنزل
دون رعاية طبية ، المزيد من
الفحوصات الافتراضية يجب أن تعني عددًا أقل من المرضى
يتزاحمون في المستشفيات حيث الموارد
لقد امتدت بالفعل بشكل لا يصدق بشكل لا يصدق ،
وأعتقد أنها لحظة اندلاع من بعض النواحي
لأنني أعتقد أننا نقول الآن ،
ها هو عرض القيمة الحقيقية
لما
تسمح به تكنولوجيا المتجر للرعاية الصحية
ألا تتعامل جميع شركات الطب عن بعد
مع kovat 19 بنفس الطريقة
قام التنويم المغناطيسي في مينيسوتا ببناء
استبيان على شبكة الإنترنت للأشخاص الذين
يعتقدون أنهم قد يكونون مصابين بالفيروس ، لذا فإن ما
قلناه هو دعونا نطور طريقة يمكن من خلالها
لا يتعين على المريض والمزود
التفاعل في الوقت الفعلي ،
فلنأخذ أنظمة الكمبيوتر الذكية حقًا ونجعلها
تقوم بالجزء الأكبر من العمل
أثناء قيامك بمراجعة الأسئلة التي
نحسبها باستمرار في
الخلفية ، هل ما زلت مناسبًا
للرعاية الافتراضية ، وفي بعض الحالات ،
سيقول البرنامج أنك مريض جدًا ،
ما يجب عليك فعله هو الانتقال إلى إعداد عيادة
على الرغم من أن الكمبيوتر يتخذ
هذه الأحكام الأولية ، فإن أي
تشخيص نهائي يتم إجراؤه بواسطة طبيب
حقيقي يراجع إجابات كل مريض  أخذ
كل تلك البيانات والمعلومات ونقوم
بتجميعها للطبيب
لإجراء التشخيص بمتوسط 89 ثانية مع
لتزام أعلى بالإرشادات مم
يزعم التنويم المغناطيسي للرعاية الشخصية أن نظ
مه يمكن أن يزيد ال
فاءة بشكل كبير ، ويخفف الكثير من ال
بء  من الطبيب أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، لكن
ثانيًا ، يسهل الأمر عليك
كمريض حاليًا يستخدم 51 من
مقدمي الرعاية الصحية تقنية الشركة ، يقدم
21 منهم هذا kovat 19 vir
الفحص المجاني في شهر مارس شهد التنويم المغناطيسي
زيادة بنسبة 3600 في المائة في
الزيارات الافتراضية على منصته في 11 يومًا فقط
رغبة الصناعة لفترة طويلة
حيث نتوقف عن الحديث عن التطبيب عن بُعد
أو تصبح المجتمعات الافتراضية
رعاية صحية أعتقد أن هذا سيكون
الحافز لـ  هذا ولكن النمو المفاجئ
أثبت أنه يمثل تحديًا عبر
منصات التطبيب عن بُعد ،
فقد تراوحت أوقات الانتظار الافتراضية في أي مكان من بضع
دقائق إلى ساعتين
نتيجة لذلك اضطرت شركات الرعاية الصحية
إلى تعيين أطباء سريريين جدد بسرعة
لتلبية الطلب المتزايد على التنويم المغناطيسي لأحدهم
يقول إن أكثر من  تم تدريب 1400 طبيبًا جديدًا
على منصتها في شهر مارس ، حيث كانت
جميع الأدوية موجودة منذ أكثر من 25
عامًا ، وكان استخدام
الخدمات الصحية عن بُعد من قبل كل من المستهلكين
والأطباء يعانون من فقر الدم أيضًا
، وما حدث في
الأسبوعين الماضيين هو مجرد طفرة لا تصدق  ذات
أهمية من حيث خدمات الرعاية الصحية عن بعد
لا يزال بعض المرضى مترددين في استخدام
التطبيب عن بعد هناك  على الرغم من أنه
بطريقة ما غير شخصية وفي
الحقيقة تعلمون جميعًا أنك تفاعلت
مع طبيب أو طبيب
سريري وجعلتهم يقدمون لك الكثير من الخدمات
دون أن يمدوا أيديهم إليك ، لذا فإن
جزءًا منها هو التغلب على هذه الأسطورة
بطريقة ما  إنها الأم الثانية يا سيدي
[موسيقى]